pour les familles des manifestants
arrêtés
l'heure est au soulagement en pleurs il
assiste à la libération de leurs proches
sans parfois pouvoir contenir leur
émotion
alexander vix un étudiant de 19 ans
témoigne des violences subies durant sa
détention
ces hématomes sont impressionnants il
l'est imaginer les coups reçus en prison
[Musique]
ils nous ont frappés
tout de suite ils nous ont traités comme
si nous étions des terroristes ou
quelque chose comme ça donc ils nous ont
frappés très durement en tapant sur nos
jambes mais aussi sur tout le corps ils
nous ont frappés sur le dos nous étions
allongés à plat ventre tout en étant
menotté bien sûr d'abord ils nous ont
frappés ensuite ils nous ont interrogés
il y avait des gens qui venaient disait
laissez-moi frapper quelqu'un je n'ai
frappé personne de la journée ensuite on
leur a donné des matraques et indiqué
qu'il pouvait frapper gratuitement il
frappait quand il y avait une raison de
le faire
il frappait aussi qu'il n'y avait aucune
raison de le faire il inventait des
prétextes et faisait tout ce qu'il
voulait sur place des médecins
volontaires sont présents pour prodiguer
les premiers soins aux ex détenus
blessés
nous avons déjà vu de tous crâne
fracturé on n'est qu'à ses côtes cassées
nous avons soigné plus de 30 personnes
en seulement deux heures depuis la
réélection d'alexandre loukachenko
dimanche soir les manifestations se
succèdent pour contester la légitimité
de son sixième mandat
des ouvriers se sont même mis en grève
pour faire entendre leur mécontentement
et dénoncé les violences à l'encontre
des protestataires
des revendications qui ne semble pas
inquiéter le président biélorusse
on a besoin de retenir personne si les
gens veulent travailler aller travailler
si une personne ne veut pas travailler
on ne va pas la force et signe
d'apaisement ce vendredi place de
l'indépendance
malgré la présence d'ouvriers en grève
venus manifester devant le palais du
gouvernement
ces policiers anti-émeutes qui gardent
leur bouclier baissé en signe de paix
des citoyens leur ont offert des fleurs